der deutsche Webvideopreis wirft seine
Schatten raus genauer hier ein
wunderbarer Schlagschatten für alle
Video Freaks oder sonst befinde ich mich
ihnen herrlichen Weilheim mitten in
Bayern was hat mich eigentlich dahinter
schlagen ich weiß es nicht mehr aber
wichtig für dieses Video ist jetzt auch
mehr was den Webvideopreis betrifft denn
ich habe was zu vergeben und zwar fünf
super sensationspakete an Tickets für
das Youtuber Treffen am Samstag um 15
Uhr und für die glanzvolle Gala abends
dann in einem super schicken Kino so und
was müssen wir dafür machen ihr müsst
beantworten wo findet der deutsche Video
Preis statt und das mailen an Exo mit
gmail.com hier unten eingeblendet und es
gibt noch mal fünf Tickets für das
Youtuber Treffen am Nachmittag extra
dazu so auch diese Frage beantworten und
wenn es mehr Fragen antworten gibt die
korrekt sind dann entscheidet wie immer
das Los ansonsten gibt es in dem Video
Preis auch für alle die nicht kommen
live zu sehen auf
webvideopreis.de ab 19:30 Uhr ich freue
mich wenn er dabei seid und bis dahin
noch mal also bis zum 29 inklusive das
Wort nicht vergessen votet wurdet ihr
könnt noch die Publikumspreise
beeinflussen also alle Links sind
übrigens unten auch für Tickets für
Youtuber treffen kaufen kosten 5 € für
Location Security und so weiter und so
fort also ich freue mich euch auf jeden
Fall dort zu sehen und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran